[Music]
but when I did theater in high school
and I was brave enough to join the class
at all because I was terrified to even
join drama with 15 kids but standing on
a stage there feeling like oh man
something you know like teleports me I'm
I'm brave on stage but in life I'm very
fearful and then stand up uh Open Mic
nights right after I graduated high
school when I would take the mic in my
hand
it just that was the only place that I
felt really uh present and I felt like I
had something that I had to put my whole
heart into that meant something to just
me but also if I succeed in it make the
people laugh maybe it'll perpetuate me
forward and have purpose in life so it
was kind of like all it was all building
up to that first open mic night in
Boston that I finally realized man I I I
found some importance in myself to me
for me I mean that would be terrifying
for just about every single human being
in the world I mean it'd be terrifying
for me because I and I don't mind being
on a stage or talking or anything it's
like that doesn't bother me
but to have it be comedy like to find
someone that is willing to stand on
stage and someone that's willing to be
vulnerable enough to I mean it's an
immediate reaction either you let people
laugh or they don't they're equal they
are both a reaction and so I I'm like I
want to like um I want to excavate this
a little bit like how what is it that's
happening have you you I don't know if
you've gone into this or figured it out
but what is it when you get the mic and
get on stage is it
you know something's flowing through you
having sometimes with creatives they're
they're like the song or the book or
whatever comes through me I it's not me
it's something coming through me is it
something like that or is it like uh do
you enter like a different sort of like
mental Dimension where you're because I
think that with my racing when I raced I
was like I mean shoot I think you enter
a different frequency with your mind
that you know no matter what is going on
it gets eliminated and I always use the
stupid example of I was like hopped up
on DayQuil one morning uh before I drove
Martinsville and it was just a practice
day but I took the DayQuil before I ate
and I was like whoa I feel drunk and I
had to go around Martinsville which is
this half mile flat track where it's
just accelerating breaking accelerating
breaking and I was like holy how am
I gonna do this and I was like super
fast and I was like oh and I never felt
it which made me realize that we don't
we're not in the same space out there
that we are in regular life so do you
feel like because I know for me and you
as a an athlete and I'm the son of an
athlete my dad went to BC boxing
basketball football super super
confident
um
you're a pressure player you're a
pressure performer probably in more
areas than just the racing where you
probably don't even realize what you're
capable of sometimes until it goes wrong
yeah yeah that's true that's true I I've
kind of even realized that with like my
best races were usually the ones where
there was the most pressure it's like
Indy 500 Daytona 500 like the ones that
were bigger were the ones that like you
know it was five years ago today
actually I just posted a story that um I
qualified in the top nine it's like this
fast nine and there's it's hard to do
and um I hadn't driven in Indy car in
seven years and I went back and like
qualified really well and so yeah you're
not you don't know what you're capable
of until you get in that position so
back to you like what is happening what
what do you feel up there or what don't
you feel well kind of you know hitching
it onto the pressure player was I wasn't
very good in school
um I wouldn't really do homework I
avoided I was terrible at many math and
certain things
um
when I tried to do homework in advance I
would get you know like C minus or
whatever but when I had one hour and
before the class was frantically trying
to learn what I needed to or I had to
kind of make it up on the Fly I was
great and I would be like wait how am I
getting A's and B's when I'm kind of
terrified putting myself in a hole
jump that into stand up
um I don't write a sent list down I at
first I used to try to write the sent
list you know you're and what I found
was that like oh man when I try to stick
to this I feel false but when I wing it
um I say things that I'm I don't even
know how I did that and I'll find
language and vernacular out of nowhere
like you know words will come in and so
I start to realize oh wow I'm I'm I am
an athlete I am the son of my father
and I'm better when I'm not so
conditioned and formulaic that's the
thing I was better when I could kind of
improvise and what that helps in stand
up is then you're kind of reading the
room if you go into a room you I'm gonna
say these five funny things but you're
not thinking of like how's the night
been is the crowd a good crowd what's
happening in the world culture uh is the
manager screaming at somebody at the bar
and that's making people nervous in the
back is there a waitress and she's uh
you know dealing with somebody who could
potentially be like threatening or a
Heckler you have to be able to go into a
situation and go here's my routine but
I'm fluid
and that's scarier because you're not
leaning on anything you're just trusting
you're going to be okay the only thing I
could ever bring it to stand up that I
think people understand in sports is
it's kind of like being a pitcher in
baseball it doesn't matter how great
your last pitch was you're up there
alone
everybody's waiting for you to do
something great and doesn't the perfect
mechanics and the perfect pitch don't
matter that next pitch the crowd doesn't
nobody cares even though that was a
great pitch and it's like that in stand
up I Gotta Laugh doesn't matter I gotta
go to the next one it's got to be as
good 90 mile an hour straight down the
middle and being in that that headspace
on stage
I felt like the person I always wanted
to be cut to leaving the stage and that
kid's still waiting for me with all the
you know early in my career people be
like man you weren't very
um uh friendly you weren't really
ingratiating yourself in the community
outside of a few Comics that I really
knew and trusted I told people years
later I was scared
I looked so confident up there at the
helm with the guy in the you know oh
yeah yeah no I was like still trying to
figure out I I had no spot I was beta
I'm very Alpha now I became Alpha I was
very beta about that then I didn't have
the the um
the confidence to look you in the eye
and let you get to know me in a very
real way I did not know how to do that
for a for a longer time than what the
stand-up indicated at first but being up
there was like a superpower and that was
the person that I wanted to be I wanted
to be me on stage in life and try to
figure out how to like reverse engineer
it to become more um present off stage
sounds like you did
I did I did yeah it took a minute but
once I started getting into the that
then you know what's so weird Danica
then I started to realize man this
up life and this how it's always
so challenging the pendulum does swing
both ways but it seems like it swings
into the hardship faster way harder
right for longer that thrust but I I
started to like I I got to a place some
years back 10 years back where I was
like I'm okay with failure I like it
I'm cool with it I wear it I up
I I find data in that I get way more
I'll fail five times and I'll still you
can go man those five things sucked I'm
winning I'm I'm picking things up from
there I'm not repeating the failure I'm
not gonna continue to do something to be
derivative and abuse myself and failure
but I got to this place where I was like
man I'm I'm really okay with this life
sometimes kicking the out of you
because that's what I think weirdly
we've all signed up for in a way I don't
know what's on the other end of it or
what the report card is after or the
simulation replay but it I I just
started to be okay with like it's okay
to not feel comfortable all the time
it's okay to feel lost it's okay to feel
um anti-climactic in your perceptions
and dreams It All Leads to what I think
is greater days and greater purpose
sometimes there's like an impetus for
that like and you know there's something
happen that made you go oh wow that
failure was actually the best damn thing
ever was there a situation that you're
that
gave you that sort of
um really strong stance to be able to be
okay with that failure because it seems
like a that's a giant lesson yeah I
think it was you know moments that
you're enlightened in realizing okay
wait how can I be so happy
in a moment of victory in a career but
then
um abuse myself in ways the way some
people will imbibe in drugs or alcohol
like I I was surrounding myself
especially in love earlier in my life
with people that were were
um you know not
kind with me not um and it was like
just people that that I felt like was
like man this is like um becoming
um
distracting almost to like the happiness
that I want to feel because of the the
purpose that I have and it took in that
enlightened moment of realizing oh I'm
I'm the son of an alcoholic and I know
the love of alcoholism and I also
realize in life we're magnets to like
want to have the same way we want to
have people identify the things that are
great about us if we have something
hidden in ourselves that's either needs
to be forgiven or wants the opposite or
something you know the toxicity feeling
polluted you you will bring people in
your life to pull that out of you as
well because that is your truth you will
be Victorious and you will feel
worthless and you'll find people to help
accentuate both it's not just one-sided
and wins make the the the you know the
the dark stuff go away no you'll you'll
be in relationships where you're like
man this person is pulling out the
couple of things the minutia that I
don't like about myself and I I'm with
that person because I want them to
reveal me to me well we can't see
ourselves that's the damn conundrum of
being that we can't it's like a computer
doesn't know it's a computer right like
it doesn't know the programming it has
no idea it's like iOS 3 or whatever I
don't even know and so you don't know
what your programming is and especially
because so much of it happens until
we're about six seven years old is when
most of our subconscious programming is
established which is about 95 of how we
operate
so we see ourselves through other people
which is just crazy and like almost no
one knows and gets that right so how
where where did you stumble upon that
because I'm 41 and I just figured that
out like you know
a few years back I had a buddy about 10
or 11 years ago
um one of my best friends and he sat
down he said um
you uh
you seek love from alcoholics you you
seek the love of alcoholism and crazy I
don't drink
never had a drink or drug in my life and
and and but it was an aha moment because
in it I was like
I understood almost immediately when he
you know just said it straight up he's
like and he brought up some examples and
he's like this person came into your
life suddenly they were athletic like
you and they want to go rock climbing
and this that and they don't drink at
all and then five months later they're
you know just day drinking and this and
that and he goes what would your dad do
I say my dad would drink and then for
three weeks it would be I'm sorry and
the best love ever until and then it
turned into that you know same Perpetual
state of like oh my goodness like what
how do we get through this as a family
and then he would sober up in four
months and it was and that's what I knew
and it was like I I hug him every time I
see him and I thank him almost like the
same day that he brought it to my
awareness that he loved me enough to go
that's who you're drawing in and so I
just you know started I don't know
sussing out the kind of people and what
their backstory was you got to learn
about people you know you gotta know
your origin you gotta in friendships and
anything in business gotta ask questions
get to know people get to know their
intentions see how mindful they are and
then from that I built uh a better
communication process for
falling in love or anything changed all
my friendships even some of my
friendship I recalibrated my whole life
based around that understanding of like
um I need healthier people around me if
you like this clip and you want to hear
the whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen